Hey, my name is Lisa, and I have a cow.
So that means everyday I milk her.
Here is the process of putting up her milk
after I milked her.
First, I need to sanitize my whole working area.
And I'm gonna pick out some bottles
that I wanna put the milk in today.
I'm picking the square bottle
because I really like it.
And I'm not selling this milk today,
so I get to keep this.
It stays at my house.
And I picked two half gallon jars
that I might sell to somebody else.
This is a dairy filter.
This is for dairy milk only people.
Some people use, like,
rags and coffee filters,
and this is specifically designed to filter milk,
and that's what it's good for doing.
I'm not gonna use a coffee filter and rewash it,
because that is gross.
Just my opinion.
Now I just need to pick up this heavy 2 gallons of milk.
Well, it was about two and a half gallons.
Um, I got enough jars of the two gallons,
but it ended up being two and a half,
and the dog got half a gallon.
Now the milk will flow pretty fast for the filter.
Now, if she has mastitis,
there'll be some,
like, boogers and goop and grossness in the milk,
and the filter will catch that
and it will start slowing down.
And I will stay in the filter.
Today she doesn't have any issues
and she hasn't Had issues in a long time.
So this milk is healthy and good to consume.
The filter is used to filter out mastitis.
And any other issues in the milk.
Could be just like a fly,
a piece of dust,
a piece of hay,
all that stuff.
You don't want the milk.
And this will work to get it all out. The milk.
Then I'm gonna retrieve my sharpie
that I hide from the kids,
and write today's date.
This is the date that I milked the cow.
And the milk will be good for two weeks
from the date that it was milked,
as long as I get the milk in the fridge within one hour.
This milk has been out of Cora for about 20 minutes,
so we're still in the good time.
Soon as I'm done filtering this milk,
getting some jars,
I will throw it straight in the fridge,
in the back of the fridge,
to try and get it chilled as fast as possible.
This is really important
because all the bacteria that's in the milk,
I want the good bacteria.
I don't want the bad bacteria to start to take over
and sour the milk faster.
Now I'm gonna place some reusable plastic lids on top.
They seal pretty nicely.
And I'm gonna dry the jars
to make sure there's no cross contamination
into my fridge.
And here's a cool fridge shot. Enjoy.